[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: OK let's do this.
So, just a little
background, I'm from Symph.
Symph is my company.
I'm wearing a t-shirt.
Woo hoo.
But let me show you.
We are Symph.
We're based in the Philippines.
This is our team.
We're kind of wacky.
But we do websites and
mobile apps for clients.
We do a lot of projects.
We have a lot of
projects over here.
We have a lot of clients.
And for every single client
or for every single project,
we build it on App Engine.
We put our code in Bitbucket.
And someone has to do this.
Fork a boilerplate
in the repository,
grant user permissions,
create a GCP project,
create App Engine
application, set up
deployment configuration,
repeat these steps again
for the test environment,
and that usually
falls on me, the CTO.
So I've been doing
that, again and again,
almost like once every
week or twice every week.
And it's really getting tiring.
We also use Slack a lot.
So we thought, what if we
can initialize and deploy
GCP projects from Slack?
So we did just that.
So it's demo time.
So here we go.
So to make it more
exciting, I'm going
to play some epic
background music
that I got from
YouTube, Royalty-free,
just letting you know.
OK.
There.
All right.
So what we do is we just
type Symph bot help.
That's our bot in Slack.
And it tells me all
the things I can do,
including this create project,
project ID, region, which
will then initialize a project.
So I wrote this documentation.
I didn't expect
that you will have
to read it on stage from stage.
So that's a lot of words right
there, don't have to read it.
But let's try it out.
So I type create project.
Let's go, Symph, next,
demo, let's just put D 19.
Hit Enter.
And so now it's creating
a production environment
of this project as well.
And it's doing that, it's
forking the repository
and doing that.
Now, I asked this
all the time, what
do you do when you're waiting
for things that are loading?
Most of the time, you open up
another tab, browse Facebook,
and then 30 minutes later,
you're still on Facebook.
So what I tell people
to do, you do push-ups.
Come on.
Yeah.
So we're done.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So the good thing about
this, it imploded.
If it fails, I can actually
do the same command again
and try it, this time
with fingers crossed.
I'm assuming that
so many people are
doing projects in the code
labs and, I don't know,
maybe it's delaying.
I really have no idea.
I should do push-ups again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Woo hoo.
All right.
OK.
So, the second time it errored.
I don't know what's
happening really.
It says permissions error
fetching application.
But if we go over
here, it should have
the project in the console.
Oh.
Resource manager projects get.
OK, so it didn't
create the project.
I don't know why.
Let's try to create
a project manually.
This worked when I practiced.
Oh.
Google should give
me more quota.
So maybe we created too
many projects too quickly,
because they're doing this
on Slack, and we ran out.
All right.
So I'll continue with
the presentation.
I'll just show you how it's
actually supposed to be.
Round of applause, please.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So let's just imagine it works.
And I'll reduce my
background music.
So when we type a command
in Slack, create project,
it sends a message to our bot.
You know, a Slack bot, it can
be any Slack bot that you have.
And then it sends a POST
request to our App Engine app.
I'll go over the
code in a little bit.
And it acts as a coordinator.
So what it does is first,
it forks the boilerplate
in Bitbucket, then
it creates a project
and enabled services, like
Vision API, datastore API,
the APIs that we commonly use.
And it also configures a
deployment for our deployment
service that's also
running Compute Engine,
it's a custom script.
Obviously, we can do this
on [INAUDIBLE],, source
repositories, and
also cloud build.
But for now, we're running
it on a custom deployment
script on Compute Engine.
So where is all of this?
It's in this link.
And I'll go over
the code right now.
And apparently I can't click on
this thing, so I'll type it up.
GitHub.
Symphco slash GCP slack init.
How am I doing on time?
All right.
So I'm going to go, just
briefly, over the code.
I'm assuming most of
you are developers.
So here, these are the
things you need to put in.
This is public and open source.
It's my first open
source project
that I'm releasing to devs
like you, so please be kind.
I know these are supposed to
be in end and not committed,
but I did.
So, yeah, don't put it in GitHub
when you deploy it on your own.
OK.
So you have your--
just put these things in.
And what it does
is when it hit--
This is what runs when you hit
the endpoint from the Slack
bot.
So first, it forks the
repo from Bitbucket.
And then it adds the branch
merge permission, so that--
we have customers in
the company that people
can't delete the
branch or people can't
delete the repository.
That's really good to put in.
And then we create
the project in GCP
under a specific
folder in our company,
in this case, Symph projects.
And then we also
do the same thing,
we create the test
project this time.
We just add the word
test at the end.
So it's sort of like a
convention in the company.
And then we create App Engine.
So I manually add us a
sleep for five seconds,
because it takes about five
seconds for project creation,
and then you can enable
the App Engine service.
You can choose the
region where you put it.
[INAUDIBLE] Asia east 2.
We like that, because
we're from the Philippines.
And then we also create
App Engine test again.
And then this is the part
where we add it to our custom
deployment script.
And then we enable datastore.
And for the test
project as well.
And you can add other services
you want to enable here.
So basically, that's
the code base.
And it's available in GitHub.
Feel free to improve
it, make it better.
And I hope you find it useful.
And just imagine that
when I did the whole demo,
it was really amazing, and
I did so much push-ups.
And the thing about
the push-ups is
that, at least if
your script is slow,
your body is healthy, right?
OK.
If your body's not healthy,
at least your script is fast.
So if you want to connect
with me, I'm on LinkedIn.
And I'm also-- my
email is up there.
I'm happy to share
this with anybody who
also wants to use it.
So that's all.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]